Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode Three: industrialisation, new political movements, the vote for women, the First World War, and the crisis years, from 1864 to 1940.
Denmark has just lost a war and a third of its territory.
What happens next is a story of reinvention.
The end of the 1800s and the beginning of the 1900s were marked by a far-reaching modernisation of Danish society.
Industrial development got going, prosperity rose, and new political reforms were meant to secure a freer economy.
Domestically, a marked conflict arose between the landowners' party, Højre, and the farmers' party, Venstre.
And a series of new political movements saw the light of day: the labour movement, the cooperative movement, and the women's movement.
Let's start with the factories.
Industrialisation began in England already in the middle of the 1700s.
The most important causes were the development of the steam engine, the first railways at the beginning of the 1800s, and access to energy in the form of large coal reserves.
The first railway within Denmark's present borders opened in 1847, and ran between Copenhagen and Roskilde.
But industrialisation only really broke through in the second half of the 1800s.
And only after the Second World War did Denmark go from being an agricultural society to being a real industrial society.
So around 1850, and for a long time after, most Danes still earned their living in agriculture.
The beginning of industrialisation made large parts of the population move from the countryside into the towns, to work in industry or in crafts.
This created a completely new group in society: workers.
They often worked in the new factories or workshops in the town, and lived in small apartments in large apartment buildings.
The many industrial workers had common interests.
They wanted, among other things, to secure the highest possible wage for their work, reasonable working hours, and better safety in the workplace.
And they began to gather.
In October 1871, the International Workers' Association for Denmark was founded, as part of the international socialist movement that sought to influence workers in many countries.
In newspapers and on leaflets, the movement's leaders called for strikes and demonstrations to demand better conditions and higher pay for workers.
On their side, the employers held on to their right to manage and distribute the work.
The period was therefore marked by strikes and clashes.
The best-known clash between demonstrating workers and the authorities was the Battle of the Fælleden, which took place in May 1872.
It was a big workers' meeting in Copenhagen that ended in fighting between police and soldiers on one side, and workers on the other.
Nobody was killed at Fælleden, but many were imprisoned.
A political workers' party also emerged: the Social Democrats, Socialdemokratiet.
At the beginning it was part of the labour movement, but in 1878 it became an independent party.
And in 1884, the first two Social Democrats were elected to the Folketing.
Then comes one of the most important agreements in Danish history.
A long dispute in 1899 between employers and workers ended in September the same year with a historic agreement, the September Compromise, Septemberforliget, between the labour market's two main organisations, which today are called DA, the Danish Employers' Confederation, and FH, the Danish Trade Union Confederation.
With the agreement, the employers kept their right to manage and distribute the work.
And the workers got the right to organise and to look after their interests collectively, through trade unions and shop stewards.
For example, to negotiate pay and working conditions, or to strike according to specific rules.
The September Compromise still underlies the way agreements are made on the Danish labour market.
This way of agreeing things in Denmark is called "the Danish Model".
Now, a change in the countryside.
While industry grew in the towns, changes also happened in the countryside.
In the middle of the 1800s, Denmark had exported large amounts of grain.
But the situation changed in the middle of the 1870s.
Now steamships and railways made it possible for the USA and the Eastern European countries to export cheap grain to Western Europe, which made grain prices fall drastically.
So Danish farmers largely chose to switch to animal production.
That means raising, for example, cattle and pigs, to produce, among other things, butter and bacon, which quickly became Denmark's by far largest exports.
The most important market was Great Britain, which alone took more than half of the animal food exports in the period 1890 to 1914.
Part of this success was due to the cooperative movement, andelsbevægelsen, which came to Denmark in the same period.
That means the cooperative movement took root in Denmark in the 1800s.
The Danish cooperative movement was part of an international movement that had arisen in England in the 1840s, under the name The Co-operative Movement.
But the cooperative movement spread unusually widely in Denmark compared with other countries.
Farmers joined forces to set up, among other things, dairies and cooperative stores.
There they cooperated on buying and production, and they shared the profit in proportion to each member's turnover.
At the same time, through the cooperative movement's businesses, farmers could improve the quality of the goods.
A guiding principle of the cooperative movement was that members voted by "heads, not hooves".
It meant that a farmer, one head, who had only a few animals, hooves, formally had as much say as a big farmer with many animals.
Cooperative slaughterhouses were also set up, which gave farmers control over both production and sale of their meat.
The cooperative movement meant a lot for the development of Danish agriculture and for Denmark as a whole.
The democratic principles and the idea of equality that underlay the cooperative idea later became an important part of modern Danish society.
There are still many cooperative businesses, for example Coop and Arla, although most have by now moved far from their original basis, in both size and form of management.
The labour movement also set up businesses built on the cooperative idea.
They were called cooperative enterprises.
For example, breweries that produced on equal terms with other businesses, but where it was the workers or the consumers themselves who owned them.
These businesses were not to give profit to owners like ordinary businesses.
The vast majority of the labour movement's businesses have today been outcompeted by private businesses.
Now back to politics, and the great deadlock.
The war in 1864 was not only a military but also a political defeat for the national-liberal middle class.
The urban middle class had not only led the fight for a democratic constitution, but also the national line that had led Denmark into the war.
So the middle class stood weak.
This played into the hands of conservative circles backed by the country's landowners.
In 1866 they pushed through a change to the constitution, which was a democratic step backwards.
The king and the men with the highest incomes now got the right to elect most of the seats in one of the Rigsdag's chambers, the Landsting.
The somewhat broader right to vote was kept for the Folketing.
But the new constitution did not say how to act when the Folketing and the Landsting, which now had two quite different electorates, and thus two different political majorities, could not agree.
At the end of the 1800s the political fight between the right-wing and left-wing forces in the Rigsdag grew harder.
Both parties thought they had the constitution on their side.
The period is therefore called the Constitutional Struggle, Forfatningskampen.
Around 1870 they organised themselves into two political parties, Højre and Venstre.
Venstre, which represented the farmers, had a majority in the Folketing.
The conservative party Højre had a majority in the Landsting.
In this period, Højre governments, appointed by the king and led by the landowner J.B.S.
Estrup, pushed through a long series of so-called provisional finance laws, even though the government was in a minority in the Folketing.
The Folketing, dominated by Venstre, tried in return to block the government's policy.
The result was that all legislative work came to a standstill.
Estrup was head of government, the council president, from 1875 to 1894.
The deadlock was only broken with the Change of System, Systemskiftet, in 1901, when the parliamentary principle was introduced.
According to the parliamentary principle, it is solely the Folketing that decides who should have government power.
A government must not have a majority in the Folketing against it.
1901 became a turning point for Danish democracy.
However, the parliamentary principle was only written into the constitution when it was changed in 1953.
After long political struggles, Venstre took over government power for the first time in 1901.
But as Danish society developed, more political parties came along.
One was the Social Liberal Party, Det Radikale Venstre.
It was formed in 1905 by breakaways from Venstre.
It was especially academics and cottagers who voted for the new party.
In 1915 to 16, the old landowners' party Højre reorganised under the name the Conservative People's Party, Det Konservative Folkeparti.
The party thereby marked that it wanted to attract other voters than just the country's landowners and the wealthy middle class, and that it now recognised the parliamentary principle and equal voting rights.
The dividing lines in Danish politics also changed in the beginning of the 1900s, so that they were mainly about economic policy.
On one side stood the Social Democrats, who put great emphasis on economic redistribution between rich and poor.
On the other side were the centre-right parties Venstre and the Conservative People's Party, which more wanted low taxes and economic freedom.
In the middle of this discussion stood the Social Liberal Party.
In its history, though, the party has cooperated most with the Social Democrats.
And now to a movement that changed the country: the women's movement.
It was also at the end of the 1800s that the fight for equality really began.
The association Dansk Kvindesamfund, the Danish Women's Society, Denmark's oldest women's organisation, was founded in 1871.
It was decisive for the series of major advances in women's rights up to the 1920s.
For example, in 1875 women gained access to take the upper secondary school leaving exam, the studentereksamen, and to go to university.
The studentereksamen had to be taken at private girls' schools until 1903, when the public gymnasiums were also opened to girls.
In 1880, married women gained the right to withdraw and use their own wages.
Nathalie Zahle, who lived from eighteen twenty-seven to nineteen thirteen, was a champion of women's right to education and independence.
In 1877 she founded a girls' school, N.
Zahle's School, in Copenhagen.
In 1921, women gained equal access to most public positions, except in the military and as priests.
Further, it was at an international socialist women's conference in 1910, in the People's House on Jagtvej in Nørrebro in Copenhagen, later known as the Youth House, that it was decided there should be an international day of struggle for women.
From 1921, the observance got a fixed annual date, the eighth of March, which is today women's international day of struggle in many countries around the world.
A decisive development in this period was that Danish women got the right to vote.
In 1903 they had gained the vote, but only for the parish councils of the national church.
From 1908, women also got the vote for parish and town councils.
And finally in 1915, with effect from 1918, the constitution was changed so that Danish women got the vote for the Rigsdag's two chambers, the Folketing and the Landsting.
Denmark thereby followed the trend in other European countries, where women's movements had also pushed to secure women political influence on equal terms with men.
Worldwide, Denmark was among the first countries to introduce the vote for women in parliamentary elections.
With the same constitutional change, domestic servants, that is, people without their own household, who served and lived with another family, also got the vote for both the Folketing and the Landsting.
Thus the right to vote was expanded from covering a minority to covering the majority of the population.
Remember the sequence: 1903, 1908, and 1915 with effect from 1918.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who are the contracting parties when collective agreements on, for example, pay, pension and working conditions are made on the private labour market?
Option A: The state and the municipalities.
Option B: The government and civil servants.
Option C: Trade unions and employers' organisations.
[DA] Hvem er aftaleparter, når der skal indgås overenskomster om fx løn, pension og arbejdsforhold på det private arbejdsmarked?  A: Stat og kommuner  |  B: Regering og embedsmænd  |  C: Fagforeninger og arbejdsgiverorganisationer
The answer is C: Trade unions and employers' organisations.
It appeared in the June 2020, June 2022 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Fagforeninger og arbejdsgiverorganisationer
Question 2.
Who does DA represent when collective agreements are negotiated on the Danish labour market?
Option A: The employers.
Option B: The government.
Option C: The employees.
[DA] Hvem repræsenterer DA, når der skal forhandles kollektive overenskomster på det danske arbejds- marked?  A: Arbejdsgiverne  |  B: Regeringen  |  C: Lønmodtagerne
The answer is A: The employers.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Arbejdsgiverne
Question 3.
Which political party arose in the 1870s as part of the labour movement?
Option A: The Social Liberal Party.
Option B: The Social Democrats.
Option C: The Socialist People's Party, SF.
[DA] Hvilket politisk parti opstod i 1870’erne som en del af arbejderbevægelsen?  A: Radikale Venstre  |  B: Socialdemokratiet  |  C: Socialistisk Folkeparti
The answer is B: The Social Democrats.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Socialdemokratiet
Question 4.
What is the movement called in which farmers in the 1800s joined forces to set up dairies and cooperative stores?
Option A: The grassroots movement.
Option B: The resistance movement.
Option C: The cooperative movement, andelsbevægelsen.
[DA] Hvad kaldes den bevægelse, hvor bønderne i 1800-tallet slog sig sammen om at oprette mejerier og brugsforeninger?  A: Græsrodsbevægelsen  |  B: Modstandsbevægelsen  |  C: Andelsbevægelsen
The answer is C: The cooperative movement, andelsbevægelsen.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Andelsbevægelsen
Question 5.
When did the cooperative movement arise in Denmark, with the first cooperative stores and dairies?
Option A: In the 1700s.
Option B: In the 1800s.
Option C: In the 1900s.
[DA] Hvornår opstod andelsbevægelsen i Danmark med oprettelsen af de første brugsforeninger og andelsmejerier?  A: I 1700-tallet  |  B: I 1800-tallet  |  C: I 1900-tallet
The answer is B: In the 1800s.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: I 1800-tallet
Question 6.
Which population group gave the party Venstre most of its votes at the end of the 1800s?
Option A: Landowners.
Option B: Workers.
Option C: Farmers.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende befolkningsgrupper fik partiet Venstre flest stemmer fra i slutningen af 1800- tallet?  A: Godsejere  |  B: Arbejdere  |  C: Bønder
The answer is C: Farmers.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Bønder
Question 7.
Which party did workers typically vote for in the middle of the 1900s?
Option A: Venstre.
Option B: The Social Democrats.
Option C: The Social Liberal Party.
[DA] Hvilket parti stemte arbejdere typisk på i midten af 1900-tallet?  A: Venstre  |  B: Socialdemokratiet  |  C: Radikale Venstre
The answer is B: The Social Democrats.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Socialdemokratiet
Question 8.
Which party did farmers typically vote for in the middle of the 1900s?
Option A: The Danish People's Party.
Option B: The Conservative People's Party.
Option C: Venstre.
[DA] Hvilket parti stemte landmænd typisk på i midten af 1900-tallet?  A: Dansk Folkeparti  |  B: Det Konservative Folkeparti  |  C: Venstre
The answer is C: Venstre.
It appeared in the June 2020 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Venstre
Question 9.
In which decade did Denmark's first railway line open?
Option A: The 1780s.
Option B: The 1840s.
Option C: The 1910s.
[DA] I hvilket årti åbnede Danmarks første jernbanestrækning?  A: 1780’erne  |  B: 1840’erne  |  C: 1910’erne
The answer is B: The 1840s.
It appeared in the November 2021, May 2024 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: 1840’erne
Question 10.
In which sector did most people work around 1850?
Option A: Industry.
Option B: Fishing.
Option C: Agriculture.
[DA] I hvilken sektor arbejdede der flest mennesker omkring 1850?  A: Industri  |  B: Fiskeri  |  C: Landbrug
The answer is C: Agriculture.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Landbrug
Question 11.
On which day is women's international day of struggle marked?
Option A: The eighth of March.
Option B: The fourth of May.
Option C: The fifth of June.
[DA] Hvilken dag markeres kvindernes internationale kampdag?  A: 8. marts  |  B: 4. maj  |  C: 5. juni
The answer is A: The eighth of March.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 8. marts
Question 12.
Through which constitutional amendment did women get the vote for the Folketing?
Option A: The amendment of 1866.
Option B: The amendment of 1915.
Option C: The amendment of 1953.
[DA] Ved hvilken grundlovsændring fik kvinder valgret til Folketinget?  A: Grundlovsændringen i 1866  |  B: Grundlovsændringen i 1915  |  C: Grundlovsændringen i 1953
The answer is B: The amendment of 1915.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in May 2025.
[DA] ✔ B: Grundlovsændringen i 1915
That's the end of Part One of Episode 3.
In Part Two, we continue with the First World War, the Reunification and the crisis years.
See you there.